I mean he was a creative director on
that then he's a tremendous writer he
wrote Halo 3 he wrote Halo reach you
know author of contact Harvest he wrote
addicts Halo Wars he's a big Dan hoyler
300 OST co-corrective director of
Destiny this resume is insane you know I
mean um obviously you know helped got
off the couch helped with uh he was a
senior corrective creative director at
Microsoft and then from there um got off
the couch to kind of helped when he
heard the infinite thing was where it
was at and you know they needed like he
they could provide his services so he's
gonna have a tremendous respect for me
my whole thing is
you know whatever state Halo was in
Prior
would be very interesting to me to find
out because there were some things we
heard that he again in a consultant role
the game's pretty much already have what
their core vision is but course
correction and then having the cashier
to be like look we need the delay I
thought that was big you know at the
time for to delay it